I did one round of Ketruda and did just fine with minimal side effects. They decided to spread out my treatments and give me a double dose for round two.
This gave me extreme fatigue and Bell's paulsy.
That's not good. So Bell's paulsy is a is a cranial nerve, seven facial nerve paulsy.
Talk about that in just a second.
Which they say is temporary and the steroids seem to be helping. I know you cannot tell you what to do either way. I'd love your opinion.
But I'm not on the cell you write out. I can't tell you what to do with drugs. I know you have to do what your ecologist is asking you to do, but I'm not in favor of doing a double dose of any type of immunotherapy or chemotherapy.
I'm thinking that, oh, we'll just hit it double. We're going to skip one and do a double dose this time to be that is just done right danger. I don't, I just don't understand their thought process with that Bell's paulsy can happen when you have any type of inflammation.
This, this is cranial nerve seven. It comes out of the base of the skull. And it's the facial nerve. So typically it'll be on one side, you'll get a complete drop of your face.
And it's, it's, oh, you know, typically, so if a person has Bell's paulsy and they had no precipitated issues like condition cancer and using a chemotherapy or a beautiful therapy that would have stimulated it typically Bell's paulsy.
It can be from a virus can be from, you know, stressful incident can be from attributed to cervical spine, bowel alignment, some oxidation.
And one of the things that you need to do is stimulate that nerve because you do not want that nerve to die.
So I used to see Bell's paulsy patients in my office. You want to take a brush like a, like a figured out brush.
Of course, brush it to scrub your fingernails with. And you want to push it under your skin and stimulate your skin. You need to stimulate that facial nerve. You can't let that facial nerve die.
The longer that you have Bell's paulsy, the more possible it is to fix Bell's paulsy. The person came in with Bell's paulsy that they just just noticed the effects of it just a few days or a week previous.
We can always 100% get them back to normal. If it was weeks or months and they've been having this Bell's paulsy that it was made it more difficult as the nerve ends up.
The crossing. So you have to stimulate that nerve. So I used to teach people to stimulate that nerve, stimulate that nerve using a brush using hot and cold water.
Getting adjusted. I would go to the chiropractor and get adjusted. Make sure they do low force technique given your condition.
Do everything you can to stimulate that nerve.
The reason why the steroid is helping is because it's anti-inflammatory. So you have inflammation of that nerve. So you don't you want to keep that nerve awake and alive.
I'm still on a feeding tube. So even crush pills are hard to get through. Are there any liquid supplements who'd suggest to help. I would definitely be on high dose curcumin with Bell's paulsy.
And that is the curc the liquid liposomal curcuclear and you could use that. That's a liquid.
If you if you're mixing up your drinks like the greens and different things like that into a smoothie, you can water them down really good so that you can use that.
And any other liquid so I'd like to give that some thought maybe we should have a conversation.